hello everyone and welcome to a game
I've mentioned yesterday that I'm gonna
show you and a lot of you have been
saying that you would like to see a
preview of the candidates to talk a
little bit of about the candidates about
the candidates tournament and such so I
decided to show you the first ever game
played between Dingley rand and Fabiano
Caruana it's from the 2015 Tata Steel
masters edition and before we check it
out I would just like to mention
something Magnus said in his stream a
few days ago he says he said that
regarding the candidates that he would
put Fabiana Caruana sort if you consider
the candidates to be in leagues then for
example Fabi would be a one league then
ding would be be one league and then all
the others would be some League below
that so he considers Fabi to be the
absolute favorite then being slightly
behind him and then all the rest now I
would just like to show you that these
are the scores between Bingley Ren and
Fabiano Caruana
throughout their life so considering
classical games Fabiano Caruana
says tied the England 2 to 2 with six
draws so out of the 10 games they played
ding one two Fabi one two and six game
was were drawn so a bit of a bit of an
equal match match up and including rapid
slash exhibition games ding Lutheran
beat Fabiano Caruana four to three with
nine drawers so that's including rapid
and exhibition games so when you
consider the scores ding definitely has
the upper hand but we're gonna see we're
gonna see what happens
so this is a really complicated game
like I said the first game ever between
the two of them I do hope you enjoy it
and if you enjoy if you enjoyed this
preview maybe you know mention it or you
know say something about it so we're
gonna check up on the other candidates
as well so ding with the white pieces
opens with d4 that we have Knight to f6
c4 and the g65 egos for the Kings Indian
defense we have g3 c6 now preparing to
go d5 Bishop to G 2 ND v we have Knight
to f3 and Bishop to g7 far between
Cato's the dark square bishop we have
castles and castles and we transpose
into the the new room fold
with b3 preparing to develop the dark
square bishop also by fee and carrying
and now in in modern games some like
Bishop to f5 or nights that efore would
be played but in 2015 D captures and c4
was the fabi's choice we have B captures
and now c5 saying that you cannot go d5
as then I just move my knight anywhere
and you are in big problems you you will
not be able to save your rope well you
can save the rook you can give up the
night and then move the rook but either
way you are at least losing the piece
so just Bishop to b2 the pawn cannot be
advanced and now Queen to b6 developing
the queen putting more pressure on d4
but also attacking the undefended bishop
here so Queen to c1
and now C capture sin before we Knight
captures and d4 biding and the knight to
c6 the in traits captures captures you
cannot capture with the Queen as the
bishop guards c6 and now Knight to d2
preparing to bring the Knights to b3
which will be very useful guarding the
c5 and the d4 squares as you'll see
later on with Bishop to F 5 by Fabi
there are some games where the bishop
was developed the e6 or G for about 5 e
decides that F 5 is the square ninth the
b3 and now comes look a to c8 there is
one game where rook F to d8 was played
in a game between Hari Krishna and
Svidler it was two years after this game
in 2017 but that game ended in a draw
but in this game
Fabi went for rook a to c8 and it is a
move move 14 that we have a completely
new game so dingos for efore and E for
is a really really tricky move because
it's impossible to capture the pawn
first if you go with the Bishop capture
then it's just Bishop captures and f6
you remove the defender of the bishop
and if you if we go into the capture
fest with Bishop captures captures
captures and captures then after all is
said and done real characters king or
queen characters white is just up a
piece so that's not going to work
another thing after efore if you capture
with the night then it's even quicker
quicker just Bishop captures here at
King captures and now g4 removes the
defender of the night so we remove the
bishop or capture but either way you
lose either the night or the bishop
so Bobby has to move the bishop with
Bishop to e6 maybe one of the reasons
why the bishop was not developed five in
in a lot of games but okay mr. back to
e6 and now even he five by dink
deciding to close up the dark square
Bishop diagonal but opening up the light
square bishop diagonal so Knights the d7
putting pressure on the pawn here and
now rook e1 defending it and c5 now here
the c6 pawn is no longer a target and
now fob you might have some ideas maybe
he can bring the knight over to d4 we'll
see it all depends on what it in place
dingos night to d2 now adds another
defender to the to the pawn here as
Bobby can easily attack and maybe wait
to bring the Queen into the attack maybe
even bring the rook into the attack so
nice to d2 we Queen the a6 now putting
more pressure on the pawn here and rook
to e3 the rook will be very useful and
he's trying to he will try to use it to
kick away the Queen so rook to b8
putting more pressure on the B file and
rook a3 now Bobby moves to b6 we have
looked a b3 and now Bobby doesn't want
to repeat to grab a draw by a threefold
repetition he moves the Queen back Queen
to c7 and now f4 and this is now a
beautiful punch in the dink created here
and if well it is gonna remain like that
unless Fabi is able to execute f6
sometimes in the future and then break
the chain down so tonight's the b6
adding another attacker to the c4 pawn
and now rook the b1 preparing to move
the bishop and then you'll have nicely
double-double rooks here on the B file
which will be very useful so rook beat
the b8 Bobby decides that he's not gonna
try and counter dings rooks and the B
file but rather he transfers the rook to
another open file we have Bishop the c3
now
the rooks are nicely doubled and also
Bishop to a5 might be an idea pinning
the night and also just adding adding a
third attacker to the night so Queen to
d7 prematurely unpinning
and now Bishop to f1 not not allowing
any infiltration by Queen to D 3 so
Bishop to f1 for the moment abandoning
this
agonal and now push up the f5 with an
attack on the rook but also maybe now
Bishop to d3 will be a possibility we
have looked at a 1 and now only now with
fabric goes for it with f6 he wants to
destroy this beautiful pawn chain we
have it captures he captures on f6 and
now rook the b5 now with the idea of
capturing and c5 but Fabi goes Knight to
a4 defense and also attacks the bishop
here we have Knight the b3 now with a
double attack on the pawn here but Fabi
just gets rid of the dark square bishop
so captures we have Queen captures and
now comes Bishop the e4 by Fabi and it's
a it's really a question do you capture
on c5 or don't you capture on c5 because
it's extremely complicated now I will
show you what happens if the c5 point is
captured but but only because it's just
beautiful so if Knight captures on c6
for example with an attack on the Queen
Queen to c6 getting the Queen out of the
way and now let's say Knight captures on
e4 you're gonna play not captures right
away but f5 and now you open up a
discovery here so both the Queen and the
rook are under attack and now after the
Queen moves you pick up some material
with a bishop card for Sunday one Queen
captures only want and now Queen
captures on e4 and yes you do have this
beautiful diagonal but it's not going to
be easy to use it for example if you
could get this Bishop to c4 somehow it
would be great but you can for example
if c5 freeing the square for the Bishop
rook to d2 and now already you have some
some very nice ideas like Queenie 3
check fall by a followed by some mating
pattern so let's take Queen c3 but now
you get Queen e1 with the threat of
Queen f2 checked followed by Queen 2h to
mate and also your opinon the bishop so
Bishop to c4 is not not possible
so here Queen to f3 defending and now
rook to e8 just preparing to bring the
other work into the game and now we
would have a race a let's say c6 King g7
c7 and now just rook captures an a2
look the b8 now preparing the Queen
Queen the pond but now Queen to d2 with
the threat of checkmate and now there's
not
more for you to do if you bring the
Queen over to h1 it's Queen to F to mate
and if you try something like Queen G to
then it's just Queen to D for check you
have to move the King rook captures and
G to you grab the Queen threatening mate
so white doesn't get a chance to bring
your Queen into the game after King
captures now you play Queen to d7 and
you've stopped everything
Bishop to a6 is also possible if you
capture if you capture and c7 then look
here just picks up the Queen so here you
have Queen to c6 check King to h3 and
now you pick up the bishop again
guarding the square and after rook
captures here yes white is a threatening
promotion here but you have Queen to f1
check King to h4 and the Queen to g2
threatening to capture with maid again
you don't allow any any tricks but
rookie 7 check King of 6 and now h3
white white is safe now from checkmate
but Queen to c6 and that's it if the
rook moves then well if the rook doesn't
cover the the c8 square then you can
never promote and if the rook moves you
can simply capture and you will push
you're a pawn to victory so I know it's
a it's a bit of a longer line than I
show usual but it's forced and it's it's
just beautiful so not the greatest move
to capture which ding doesn't but ding
funk fine finds an incredibly
complicated idea f5 and this is just the
point of a focus so next move for
example if he captures you will not have
that free move f5 by black opening up a
discovery here so that's the purpose of
f5 but it's not gonna go as planned as
family decides he captures on f5 and now
again for example if you capture on c5
then you get Bishop the c6 could be very
annoying for example this rook is under
attack sorry my TV just started making
sounds for no reason
yeah no idea what it happened but yeah
if Bishop to c6 attacking the rook and
b5 you'd have to move it to a really
ugly square as you do have to keep an
eye on the night and then after you move
it just look after I ate and now when
you get control of the e3 squared Bishop
to h6 followed by Bishop to e3 and it's
game over as this Bishop nicely covers
the light square diagonal so again it's
not all that great to capture it but
first rook to e1 as the file will be
will be the place where where the pieces
confront we have rook F to eat biting
and only now rook captures on c5 finally
winning winning that pawn and here Dean
creates the past C pawn so here Fabi as
the queen is under attack Fabi played
Queen to d7 but there is another move a
move that is well that could win the
game on the spot a Fabi missed it but
you're comfortable I hope in your home
and feel free to pause the video and try
to find this brilliant tactic shot that
fab you missed well I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations as its
it's not an easy move to find and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's actually Queen captures on c5
and it does look weird but again the
point is this free mu F 5 for example
not you have to capture as it's with
trick so Knight captures Queen and now
f5 opening up a discovery here the
problem is if you move the Queen let's
say queen c1 then you get Bishop to d4
with check and there's not much for you
to do you have to block with something
if rook e3 you just pick up the night
here and everything is tied down there's
not much you can do let's say Queen C 3
you just move the bishop back open up
another discovery here now there are two
pieces attacking the rook King F to
defending but now just rook captures
Queen characterís and you can pretty
much either capture the Queen right away
or rug did you check and not allow even
that Bishop e2 captures captures
captures and you get this endgame where
where Bobby would have a rook and ding
would
so that's what happens if Queen captures
displayed but there's also a possibility
of characters characters and f5 opening
up a discovery and now let's say you try
and give back some material with rook
captures on e4
but then Bishop captures and c3 captures
with Czech captures back and it's the
same game where fabi's again of the
exchange and well in a winning endgame
so not really not really sure what
happened there if it's an easy move to
miss but you know it is completely
winning so Queen to d7 by Fabi and now
comes Queen to c1 so what do you do here
f5 of course will no longer be a
discovery on the Queen but still f5 of
course you do have to play it and now
Queen to f4 biding with some idea so
maybe going rook to c7 as the Queen
nicely defends it so look the e7
guarding the c7 square and now h4 biding
but now he gives Fabi another
opportunity where if Abby found it or
not we're gonna have to wait and see but
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for black
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
really congratulations III would say
this move is even harder than the
previous one but I'll let you I'll let
you decide so for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's a 5 really
really cool stuff because you're
actually just threatening a four to kick
away the defender of the d4 square and
then ship the d4 will be deadly point is
if you block it with a four then if a
four then Queen just captures and then
the knight is under attack the sea the
knight is under attack and it's well
it's not pleasant still you have to move
it Bishop to d4 is coming if for example
you play rook captures then you don't
really gain anything but for example if
you play rook captures which was played
in the game so we're gonna get back to
that but the point is if you play after
a 5 let's say Knight captures which is
possible then Bishop d4 just picks up
the rope so the only thing that being
found was the capture with the rook Fabi
played Bishop the c3 with
and both rooks and now comes looked at
d5 by ding
and here ding is hoping for better
captures and e5 which would result in
characters characters and characters
with ding having this well fairly strong
passed pawn a point being you cannot
capture it because just Bishop to c4
winds back material so the Fabi decides
not to capture a fob instead goes Quinta
a7 width track we have Quinta h2 and now
only now rook captures on d5 and now
ding is down down material he has to do
something he played see captures on d5
but now just better captures anyone and
it was in this position that dinkler and
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here both players as you
can see two pieces two pieces but Fabi
also has a look on the side so due to a
severe material loss dinkler and
resigned the game and that was it he
does have a passed pawn but even if you
try pushing let's say d6 rook d7 there's
nothing to do Bishop the c-4 check
you're gonna go King f8 and there's no
way to continue the attack if you try
something like Queen e5 maybe to go for
checkmate it's just a quick checkmate
from black Queen if you check here and
Queen g2 will be made so no tricks up
ding sleeve he simply had to resign here
so yeah that's the first game ever
between England and Fabian Caruana I do
hope you enjoyed it and just in case you
forgot the final standings of the 2015
Tata Steel masters here they are of
course the Magnus Carlsen won it with 9
out of 13 then with 8 and a half we have
maxime beaugeois grab on each Erie
Wesley so ending leerin Vasily Vinci
with 7 and a half and Fabiano caruana
with 7 out of 13 so still not not as
strong as all the others followed by
timid our job of Slovakia Czech Lebanon
and - even cherish a lock on Valley and
module Jabba in in last place yeah
that's like I said the game I do hope
you enjoyed it if you enjoyed this
preview of the candidates do speak up
maybe we're gonna check up on some of
the other candidates and some of their
other interesting games but I will show
on another game between ding and Fabi
the second game ever they played which
is also a very interesting one so I
would like to thank Ryan bear her
Bradley Campbell and Robert
and Taylor for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous videos your thing called
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
the candidates start in two days if if
if they do yeah I think oh I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your weekend